olá pessoal bem 20 e hoje vou ensinar
como fazer com uma pistola que é muito
semelhante com a última que eu fiz só de
fé na parte em que eu conseguia destinar
esta parte do filme que dá por carregar
a arma do modo muito mais realista então
vamos lá
[Música]
para começar tem o mar como folha como
se fosse uma rifa
caso vocês não consigam fazer isso
direito vou deixar um livro de inscrição
onde ensina a fazer isso mais devagar
possa passar a bola não foi a volta da
rifa modo fazer um tubo podem prender
usando fita ou então cola branca que
fica muito mais bonita
[Música]
a esquerda tem que fazer uma rifa no
geral muito mais fina que aquela inicial
prevista em tirar um quinto triângulo e
depois podem inflar os anfitriões com o
então cola
vocês vão conhecer esta rica mais para
frente e tirar sua cor vermelha
para o tutor e aluno ficar confuso eu
fiz alguns anos para ajudarmos coisas
bonitas e quando condição dos tubos na
arma
[Música]
vou escutar em streaming todos têm
começaram a colar os tubinhos dos cinco
encontros entre o time fica por baixo
lado de ficar sem um congelamento
deslocado para mim o volátil e passam
isso até o final 82 cm site e dura tendo
em atenção a orientação dos tubos de 5
sem fim marca e uma idéia empreendedora
e cola youtubecn instinto para que o
curta e dois tubinhos de nove
centímetros e vou usar rifa vermelha era
fazer o gatilho da arma clube filho
consiste basicamente uma rifa dobrado em
uma extremidade maior tem que sair
ligeiramente por fora e extremidade do
norton ficar dentro do primeiro turno
dos cinco sentidos
[Música]
atenção você está encurtar esta parte da
extremidade por uma malha com uma
inclinação de 45 graus o que é muito
importante que faz ações
[Música]
utilizando marido fábio maia estou
fazendo agora o corda madrid vai jogar
bastante simples tem por cola na
extremidade encaixar dentro do tubo de
cinco centros e depois modular e colar
na outra para tal seja no cam
[Música]
agora vou fazer uma rifa mas ao
contrário da inicial esta fica oca por
dentro continuassem espalmá la
facilmente e depois devo utilizá la para
contornar empunhadura da arma aumentando
assim bastante a existência dela
[Música]
além dos estudos de novos centros do
modo que a parte inicial dos tubos
conhecido um cobarde inicial do cano
contando direita para a esquerda
para fazer o que estão a precisar de uma
rifa maia ou seja uma rifa mais fina que
a parte mais frágil e dobra em mais ou
menos três centímetros corta em mais
três centímetros e cola na parte da
extremidade melhor
para impulsionar o cristão sabe largos
como os meus um bufê 15 e usei três mas
sua voz foi mais forte podem usar um ou
então 2 depois por elásticos a
empreender usando fita os em fita porque
segura melhor do que cola uma vez que o
papel está enrolado em camadas
a pressão agora usar uma super cola e só
vai aumentar bastante a existência da
arma é isto pode não funcionar e se
vocês forem crianças peçam ajuda o dodó
cair
[Música]
esta investigue se tiver funcionar bem
precisar de três tubos em que dois erros
têm que ter o cumprimento da arma e um
de luz tem ter comprimento só tapar
tucano
[Música]
o tumulto mas vai ficar sujeito a alguma
opção então é importante que você
escolhe uma rifa dentro dele cola em
três turnos do modo indicado no vídeo
[Música]
a indústria de transformação ea
espanhola na extremidade encaixa nos
tubos maior atenção no punho muito para
dentro porque é fé é pequena e aí vai
ficar mesmo a conta
dobre do modo que vocês vão ver no vídeo
ela a intenção é que um pequeno segmento
dobrado sem ter mais o ambiente um
veículo flex int
passam mesmo do outro lado e armas já
está praticamente terminada é só vocês
passarem os livros por dentro dos tubos
de nove centímetros
do outro lado quando tiver tudo sozinho
vocês têm que encaixa dentro dos tubos
grande mas por aqui fico preso é só
vocês ponham as gotas de cola pois
encaixarem esperarem sec e pronto já
está feito é só vocês gostarem
ainda vamos ter como fazer balas que já
mostrei em outros vídeos mas é bastante
simples é basicamente um lar o papel que
isso você tem que usar óculos porque são
não podem disparar contra ninguém mas a
gente tem que ser responsável é pessoal
acho que ficou simples mas ficou muito
mais realista do que as outras
então esse pessoal chegamos o fim eu
espero que tenham gostado se vocês
quiserem ajudar o canal é só deixar um
like e se inscrevam caso não sejam
inscritos e se tiver alguma sugestão do
projeto já nos comentários
então que tal